como diría la canción no estaba muerto
estaba de parranda queridos amigos
amigas el peronismo argentino que se vio
entre la espada y la pared tras laspo
del pasado mes de agosto parece ahora
preparado y a punto para competir una
carrera electoral en la que ya se han
roto todas las previsiones Sergio Tomás
masa el abanderado peronista al que se
le auguraba una catástrofe electoral es
ahora líder de una épica remontada
encontré en cada uno de ustedes estuvo
la energía que nos
permitió que creciéramos casi 15 puntos
desde la primaria a hoy ahora bien si
algo ha quedado claro es que nada pero
que absolutamente nada está escrito en
las primarias la gran sorpresa fue
Javier Miley y luego en la primera
vuelta la campanada la dio Sergio masa
Así que para el balotaje para la segunda
vuelta hay mucha incertidumbre salvo por
el hecho de que el peronismo Está frente
a una de sus remontadas más increíbles
de su historia una que se está
produciendo en un momento económico
absolutamente crítico para el país uno
en el que incluso falta gasolina la
sorprendente Victoria muestra la notable
resistencia del peronismo Sergio masa el
ministro de economía de Argentina que
logró lo impensable ganar la primera
vuelta en un país con casi un 140 por de
inflación Argentina el candidato
peronista Sergio masa frena la ola
ultraderechista amigos la recuperación
electoral del peronismo algo con lo que
nadie contaba genera ahora nuevos
interrogantes podrá masa triunfar en la
segunda vuelta qué necesita para
lograrlo Qué representa este candidato
dentro del peronismo qué proyecto tiene
para la Argentina Pues todo esto y más
lo vamos a ver a continuación
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 2019 la fórmula Alberto Fernández
Cristina Fernández de kisner venció en
primera vuelta la candidatura de
Mauricio macri lo que llevó nuevamente
al poder al peronismo un movimiento que
ha gobernado el país 16 de los últimos
20 años sin embargo en esta ocasión la
mala gestión la pandemia el sho externo
por la Guerra de Ucrania y la inflación
galopante pusieron al gobierno y por
extensión a todo el movimiento contra
las cuerdas el país queridos amigos se
encuentra otra vez sumido en una
durísima crisis para colmo se produjeron
auténticas batallas campales en el seno
del propio gobierno así que podemos
decir que entre unas cosas y otras la
presidencia de Fernández ha sido un
auténtico desastre no fuei escuchada y
en un país de carácter presidencialista
como es este está claro que el que
decide siempre es el presidente Para
bien o para mal cómo veis la otra hora
poderosa e imbatible Cristina Fernández
llegó a ocaso de su vicepresidencia como
si se tratase de un perfil ajeno al
gobierno Mientras que el propio Alberto
Fernández es hoy un presidente tan
ausente de la agenda pública que se da
por hecho su retirado de la política
pero sea como sea en ambos casos su
nivel de popularidad está por los suelos
Y eso es un buen reflejo de lo que ha
sido el Gobierno argentino Durante los
últimos años
fijaos como podéis ver entre el 70 y el
80% de los argentinos tienen una imagen
mala o muy mala de estas dos figuras
políticas y de hecho Pese a que Alberto
Fernández es el presidente la sensación
que existe Es que desde hace varios
meses la casa rosada parece tener un
solo dirigente Sergio masa y es que
veréis para afrontar la crisis que
atraviesa el país y hacer FR a la
ruptura total de la coalición de
gobierno tanto Alberto como Cristina
presidente y vicepresidenta acordaron en
agosto de 2022 crear un super Ministerio
de economía que unificaba varias
carteras al frente estaría Sergio tomas
masa de esta forma le dieron
prácticamente las llaves y el timón del
Estado estoy convencido lo conozco a
Sergio hace muchos años vamos a
transitar
exitosamente con todos y con todas
incluidos a eso los convoco para eso lo
convoqué a Sergio cuya capacidad y
coraje me constan
y estoy seguro que lo va a serar muy
bien así comenzó el camino de esta
especie de antihéroe al que ahora los
argentinos parecen estar perdonándole
los desastrosos números que se han
cosechado en materia económica durante
el último
año un año donde hemos visto una
espectacular devaluación una inflación
galopante y un sinfín de problemas de
todo tipo que el nuevo super ministerio
no ha podido enfrentar Eso sí A
diferencia del que era el gobierno de
Fernández masa sí que se ha mostrado
mucho pero que mucho más activo Sergio
masa anunció dólar soja a 200 pesos y
aseguró 5000 millones de dólares las
claves masa viaja a los Estados Unidos
se reunirá con el fmi el Banco Mundial y
participará del g20 por el dólar y la
inflación Sergio masa convoca a gremios
y empresarios a negociar 90 días de
estabilidad con guiños a Sergio masa la
confederación general del trabajo
respaldará una negociación con el fondo
y apuntará a los empresarios y a Javier
Miley Es evidente que toda esta
actividad no dio precisamente un buen
resultado pero pese a ello desde su toma
de Posesión má ha tenido una agenda
frenética cada semana tenía un anuncio
un acto público o una política nueva
para anunciar el objetivo ante todo era
Mostrar que el superministro Tenía
muchos planes en marcha de esta manera
poco a poco Sergio Tomás masa se
convirtió en la cara visible de un
gobierno derrumbado eraa el único que
daba la cara por lo que al final gremios
movimient sociales y gobiernos
peronistas provinciales no tuvieron otra
figura en la cual refugiarse pero
queridos amigos amigas para entender
como massa se fue colando por las
grietas del peronismo debemos primero
entender su naturaleza su historia y su
tipo de hacer política Quién es
realmente Sergio masa a ha la ideológica
del peronismo representa Hasta qué punto
podemos hablar de un candidato
accidental pues
[Aplausos]
[Música]
atentos una persona diferentes
rostros
el 12 de julio de 1924 Durante los
Juegos Olímpicos de París Luis bruneto
con tan solo 23 años de edad logró
convertirse en uno de los primeros
argentinos en obtener una medalla
olímpica su especialidad El Salto triple
una de las disciplinas más complejas del
atletismo Pues bien Hoy casi 100 años
después Sergio masa es el máximo
exponente del triple salto cuádruple y
hasta quíntuple durante su carrera
política amigos ha sabido ser liberal
kisnerista anti kisnerista peronista
disidente y prácticamente cualquier otra
cosa que os podáis imaginar digamos que
su ideología es algo flexible Sergio
tiene varios principios y si en un
momento determinado estos Pues no son
populares probablemente nos pueda
mostrar otros
distintos la carrera de masa se inició
en los 90 militando en la ucd unión del
centro democrático un partido de
ideología liberal conservadora que se
posicionaba como tercera fuerza a nivel
nacional incluso llegó a ser presidente
de la juventud liberal en la provincia
de Buenos Aires entre 1994 1996 y aquí
fue cuando podemos encontrar su primer
salto en
1999 ya en las filas del peronismo que
en aquel momento seducía al liberalismo
con la figura de Carlos menem llegó a
ser electo diputado nacional por esta
plataforma luego en el 2001 cuando el
peronismo se hizo con El Ejecutivo tras
la renuncia de la rua masa pasó a
conducir con solo 29 años la
administración Nacional de la seguridad
social Cargo en el cual lo ratif Néstor
kisner hasta el añoo 2007 para entonces
su perfil ya era conocido como una de
las grandes promesas del peronismo del
momento jubilados evidentemente está
claro que para este gobierno los
jubilados son una prioridad la decisión
del presidente primigenia fue resolver
la situación de los jubilados que en la
Argentina después de 11 años no habían
tenido aumento y estaban en situación de
indigencia luego en 2007 pasó a ser
intendente de tigre una localidad de
casi 400,000 habitantes la provincia de
Buenos Aires sin embargo tan solo un año
más tarde en 2008 Cristina Fernández de
kisner lo llamó para convertirse Ni más
ni menos que en su jefe de gabinete
cargo que por supuesto lo situó como una
de las personas claves dentro del
gobierno
kisnerista pese a ello Sergio duró poco
en la política nacional y en 2009
decidió volver a la gestión municipal en
tigre en aquel entonces este movimiento
El Salto de la política nacional al
regreso a la política local Seguro
seguro que pareció una pérdida de
categoría pero lo cierto es que lo que
más perseguía era la construcción de su
propio poder territorial de esta forma
poco a poco masa fue creando su propia
liga de intendentes y jugando con la
idea de ser un peronista moderado en
contraste a la narrativa kisnerista y de
hecho en 2011 no Solo llegó a obtener la
reelección como intendente sino que pasó
a ser una de las autoridades locales más
votadas de toda la historia Argentina
hablamos de que ganó con el 73 por de
los votos de esta forma en 2013 su
figura representaba ya un potencial
relevo al kissnerismo lo que se ratificó
con la creación de su propia plataforma
política el frente renovador luego un
momento de ruptura prácticamente total
entre Masa y El kissnerismo se produjo
cuando Cristina Fernández quiso promover
alguna clase de reforma constitucional
que le permitiera ser elegida masa fue
uno de los voceros dentro del peronismo
más críticos con aquella
idea y finalmente cuando Cristina
Fernández tuvo que abandonar el poder en
2015 Sergio masa pasó a la ofensiva para
tratar de conquistar al peronismo
desencantado con el tramo final del
gobierno kisnerista y ojo porque lo hizo
dando un salto más no solo porque se
presentó la elección presidencial sino
porque tomó como principal rival al
propio kissnerismo a quien le dedicó
profundas críticas durante toda la
campaña queremos convocar con humildad y
generosidad a todos los sectores de la
política a discutir políticas de estado
a plantear después de esta elección que
viene un tiempo en el cual hay que
abandonar las miserias las mezquindades
ahí nos dice están tomando el control
del Estado están poniendo a fulano a
mengano yo voy a barrer a los nooki de
la cámpora que nos quieren dejar como
parásitos en el estado sea como sea en
esas elecciones masa pese a lograr más
del 20% de los votos en la primera
vuelta no logró pasar al balotaje
Mauricio macri terminaría haciéndose con
la presidencia lo que habría una nueva
etapa en la carrera de nuestro
protagonista su idea queridos amigos era
convertirse en el principal referente
del peronismo ahora cómo posiciona macri
[Música]
y ojo porque para ello fue el propio
presidente quien trató de promoverlo
como una especie de opositor responsable
hasta el punto de llevarlo al Foro de
davos en 2016 como parte de la comitiva
oficial y creo que es muy importante de
que demos la que tengamos la capacidad
de dar el mensaje de que la Argentina a
la hora de salir al mundo puede salir
gobierno y opositores con un único
mensaje sin embargo esta convivencia
política duró muy poco en 17 el frente
renovador de masa sufrió una debacle
electoral importantísima Eso sí en el
año 2019 Sergio volvió al ataque y amagó
con la posibilidad de ser candidato a
presidente sin embargo En esa ocasión
dentro del peronismo se creó una
plataforma unitaria con un solo objetivo
evitar a toda costa La reelección de
Mauricio macri creo que tenemos que
hacer el esfuerzo de construir lo más
grande posible un frente para darle un
nuevo gobierno a la Argentina en ese
contexto mi candidatura a presidente
puede esperar 4 años pasó entonces
liderar la lista de diputados de aquella
coalición Que condujo la fórmula Alberto
Fernández Cristina Fernández de kisner
una fórmula que logró hacerse con el
gobierno en la primera vuelta de las
presidenciales desbancando a Mauricio
macri Pues bien en esa Nueva etapa masa
pasó a ejercer la presidencia de la
cámara de diputados Este era una especie
de agente intermedio entre Los
partidarios de Cristina y los de Alberto
por ejemplo en marzo de 2022 la facción
kisnerista del gobierno se negó a votar
a favor del acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional por lo que masa
tuvo que manejar los tiempos y el debate
con bloques de la oposición para no
dejar al país al frente del Abismo del
default luego Poco después en julio de
2022 el ministro de economía cercano a
Alberto Fernández martinn guzm renunció
a su cargo y dejó al gabinete a la
deriva con un presidente y una
vicepresidenta que ni siquiera se
dirigía en la palabra Entonces tal y
como ya os hemos contado masa se hizo
cargo de la situación con ese super
Ministerio del que antes os hemos
hablado y asumió un entorno un escenario
sumamente complejo Sergio Tomás masa
lleva ya 15 meses al frente del
Ministerio de economía y la pregunta
queridos amigos es Cómo se las arregló
para que el peronismo llegara a la
elección presidencial con cierta
competitividad Cómo logró unificar al
peronismo tras su figura en un contexto
tan difícil pues prestad mucha pero que
mucha
[Música]
atención del plan llegar al plan
platita amigos y amigas de visual
politic los argentinos solen atribuirse
la invención de múltiples aparatos
modernos Como por ejemplo el helicóptero
la primera vez que se realizó el vuelo
de un helicóptero controlable fue en
Buenos Aires en el año 1916 cuando el
argentino Raúl pateras logró lazaña en
los cielos de la capital Argentina sin
embargo la palabra helicóptero tiene
también una connotación oscura en la
jerga política gaucha todos recuerdan
como en el año 2001 el presidente de la
ruba tuvo que ser evacuado en
helicóptero desde la terraza de la casa
rosada después de que renunciara en
medio de una enorme espiral de protestas
violencia y una crisis económica
galopante desde entonces cada vez que un
gobierno comienza a tambalearse en la
Argentina la imagen del helicóptero
comienza a ganar terreno en la opinión
pública y por supuesto en julio de 2022
cuando el gobierno argentino estaba
prácticamente a la deriva las hélices en
movimiento comenzaron a sonar en la
cabeza de varios dirigentes
políticos entonces fue cuando Sergio
massa se hizo cargo del Super Ministerio
de economía Con un objetivo muy claro
llegar pero llegar a dónde pues
inicialmente al final del mandato el 10
de diciembre de 2023 pero amigos para
poder hacerlo masa necesitaba fondos
dinero con el que mantener en
funcionamiento la maquinaria del estado
argentino y evitar que la crisis se
descontrolar Y sabéis qué buscó fondos
hasta debajo de las piedras el bid
acordó con Sergio masa y entrega 1200
millones de dólares para mejorar las
reservas masa anunció un dólar agro
unificado y buscará simplificar las
cotizaciones para importar productos y
servicios los objetivos de masa en China
ampliación del Swap bricks y reuniones
clave Argentina paga un vencimiento al
fmi con préstamo de Qatar al mismo
tiempo en paralelo más implementó duras
restricciones a las importaciones para
intentar conservar la mayor cantidad de
Divisas dentro del sistema financiero
[Música]
argentino esto se tradujo por ejemplo en
el establecimiento del sistema de
importaciones de la República Argentina
un sistema mediante el cual el gobierno
evalúa y aprueba ojo caso por caso cada
solicitud de importación sin embargo
esto no solo opera como un control de
cambios ultraconservador sino que ha
hecho que muchas empresas no puedan
acceder a suministros claves Y eso ni
siquiera es todo el problema no es ya
que el gobierno argentino otorgue pocas
licencias de importaciones sino que
encima liquida los dólares tarde y mal
lo que le ha supuesto al Banco Central
contraer una enorme deuda comercial esto
para que nos entendamos es una especie
de bomba de tiempo que más ha construido
con tal de conservar algo de oxígeno
dentro de las arcas públicas al menos
hasta las elecciones sea como sea más
allá del coste futuro que puedan tener
maniobras como estas Lo cierto es que
masa logró algo de oxígeno para que el
gobierno pudiera afrontar las elecciones
y de hecho el plan llegar se convirtió
en plena Campaña en El plan platita
luego que se tradujo en una enorme
expansión de gasto público Para repartir
a diestro y siniestro un montón de
subvenciones y prestaciones a millones
de
[Música]
argentinos después de quedar terceros en
laspo en las primarias de agosto masa y
su gabinete económico se lanzaron a la
conquista de todos los votos posibles
apuntando directamente al bolsillo de
los argentinos con el programa de
fortalecimiento del actividad económica
y del ingreso un hombre elegante para un
enorme paquete de bonos subsid idos
aportes y créditos sin precedentes en la
historia Argentina hablamos de bonos de
994.000 pesos cerca de 100 para
empleados informales la prórroga en el
pago de aportes IVA e impuesto a las
ganancias un refuerzo de 37,000 pesos
para jubilados cerca de $7 un Bono de
60.000 pes cerca de 0 para los empleados
del sector privado obligando a las
empresas a otorgarlo y el congelamiento
de los precios de combustibles entre
otras muchas medidas toda esta vorágine
asistencialista según estimaciones
privadas costó en tan solo un mes cerca
del 1,3 por del
pib y amigos si pensáis que toda esta
apuesta de masa se dirige solo a los
sectores más vulnerables estáis muy pero
que muy equivocados el candidato
peronista llegó a defender en los
debates el
previaje el previaje es un programa con
el cual el gobierno subvencion I el 50%
de tus vacaciones Sí tal cual como lo
oyes el gobierno abre un registro para
que las personas suban allí sus boletos
aéreos reservas en hoteles o excursiones
guiadas y el estado tras verificar esa
información te envía una tarjeta de
crédito con un saldo a favor equivalente
al 50% de tus
gastos los viajes de este tipo
obviamente solo están hoy por hoy al
alcance de los sectores de ingresos
medios altos estamos hablando de un país
donde seis de cada 10 son pobres Pues
bien en este mismo país el tesoro
argentino subvenciona el fin de semana
de esquí de una familia en la Patagonia
Ver para creer El caso es que todo este
despliegue económico generó importantes
réditos para el candidato peronista por
ejemplo entre as paso y la primera
vuelta de las presidenciales logró sumar
casi 3 millones de votos el plan platita
ha sido todo un éxito Claro que un
momento porque este no es el único
motivo del repunte peronista
[Música]
atentos campaña y Revancha
queridos amigos amigas os hago una
pregunta cuánto tiempo hace que no veis
una buena noticia de la Argentina desde
luego en el terreno económico y político
quizás hablemos de años por ejemplo
desde que más asumió su cargo como
superministro de economía el peso
argentino se ha devaluado cerca de un
230 por y la inflación anualizada ha
alcanzado el 140 de locos la foto
electoral así vista resulta simple
llanamente horripilante y sin embargo y
pese a todo pues ya lo veis parece no
afectarle demasiado al candidato
peronista y la pregunta lógicamente es
por qué pues por un lado está El plan
platita del que os acabamos de hablar
Pero además podemos encontrar otros dos
factores primero masa Ha logrado
presentarse como una especie de outsider
sí es el ministro de economía pero lo es
porque llegó para arreglar una crisis
ajena él no tiene responsabilidad Yo
quiero dejar claro me hice cargo de la
emergencia cuando muchos agitaban el
helicóptero o la asamblea legislativa no
me metí abajo de la cama porque amo mi
país con el mismo amor
el 11 de diciembre en la producción y el
trabajo Voy a poner en marcha la
economía en segundo lugar está la
campaña del miedo en torno a Javier
Miley el oficialismo peronista ha
desplegado una enorme batería de
anuncios sobre cómo serían los costes de
vida si se cumpliesen las promesas de
Javier Miley algo que parece que ha
calado hondo los sectores más
vulnerables luego a todo esto se le sumó
el malísimo final de campaña del partido
la libertad avanza que se dedicó a
proponer disparates o medidas que no les
hacía sino parecer pues mucho más
radicales al tiempo que se Aba la
atención de sus medidas estrellas
hablamos de cosas como por ejemplo la
renuncia a la paternidad Entonces el
proyecto es renuncia de la
paternidad la mujer cuando se entera que
está embarazada tiene 15 días para
notificar al padre y el padre debe puede
decidir si va a hacerse cargo del hijo o
no que habría que
imitar lo que hizo el presidente roca
esto es suspender las relaciones
diplomáticas con el Vaticano
[Música]
seguro que ahora entendéis mejor el
resultado pero más allá de ello nos
queda una pregunta qué propone masa Qué
defiende para la Argentina pues amigos
para empezar hablamos del ya
superministro de economía Entonces es
difícil pensar que como presidente haría
algo diferente a lo que hace ahora y de
hecho eso queda claro en su programa de
propuestas como estas que podéis ver en
pantalla básicamente amigos respecto a
la Argentina masa Confía en que todo se
arregle con algo de buena suerte pero
sin cambios estructurales es decir más
de lo mismo pero sea como sea hais
llegados hasta aquí la pregunta es para
ti quién crees que será el nuevo
presidente de la Argentina de momento en
la macroencuesta de visual potic que la
podéis encontrar en comunidad y que ya
tiene más de 120,000 votos ha arrollado
mi ley y la pregunta es estáis de
acuerdo dejadnos vuestras impresiones en
los comentarios y habramos debate y
ahora si este víde se resultado
interesante ya sabéis dadle a like y no
os olvidéis suscribiros a visual politic
si es que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez
más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la
próxima